if you want to play football you just
gotta go out there and do it
double-jointed look at this stuff bo
Boll you can't do that you were Frank
the tank that was frankly saying yo
welcome to citizen left guy you doin pal
what's up man stay over there okay dude
do not huge accident that's what you are
you're Hugh Jackson I'm Baker man are
you Baker Mayfield I'm Hugh Jackson yes
that's really offensive let's just start
there actually so that was a big social
moment that I don't know who's right
who's wrong
Baker was like he went to my rival and
he was like I'm just trying to be your
friend buddy
which side are you on it because with a
lot of people disciplining Baker well I
don't know if I have a discipline Baker
I have no problem with what Baker did as
I mean that's a player okay he said
hello to him he shook his hand I mean I
didn't know they were supposed to have a
bromance on the field so he's a
competitor I think he wanted like the
hug and like the whisper in the ear and
all that well there was obviously
something that has gone on that's rub
Baker the wrong way whether that's he's
gone to work for the bangles or maybe
the fact that Hugh was such a staunch
Tyrod Taylor defender from the start to
where I think there's got to be
something more like if Gruden went to
the Panthers midseason and left the Bucs
you wouldn't be hugging them in whisper
I mean I meant maybe it depends on how
that relationship wasn't prior but a
relationship but I could tell you
certainly I would not be happy if my
head coach left to go to a division
rival that you have to play twice a year
I just listened to all this noise of
people telling Baker to grow up and I
say no this is exactly what Cleveland
needs sure I've been waiting for someone
to get in there and say screw all of you
double birds were the Cleveland Browns
he's being the leader he's got
incredible Moxie he's got incredible
don't love someone for being like Brett
Favre and then when they do a Brett Farr
thing go oh that's too much but well
don't LA this is the conundrum athletes
are in right now more than anything is
you know when they care too much hey man
relax it's a business and then when they
don't care it's oh I wish they cared
more like the college players they care
so you can't win sometimes Baker cares a
lot he wants to win he didn't want to
give the lovefest to Hue out
they gotta play him again later on this
year so he has to beat his butt then too
well let's continue the Cleveland Browns
love fellow
let's do we have ourselves a
correspondent you may say in Cleveland
rookie Denzel Award having a great year
at cornerback yep and he went around to
a bunch of the Browns and tried to find
some hidden talents on the Browns roster
I'm Denzel war we're here at feeds the
need in Cleveland Ohio let's see what
analyst these guys got that I think
myself is a pretty good chef you know I
throwed out in the kitchen a little bit
I'm kind of a meat and potatoes guy so I
do a pretty good steak I do like a
reverse sear on it on my smoker I like
it my wife likes it so we're good I got
my quarterback Baker Mayfield I heard
you got an impression Baker so Freddie
kitchens our offensive coordinator and
what you see is what you get with Baker
he's raised in Alabama so he talks like
this I meant if you want to play
football you just gotta go out there and
do it I mean if you love the game you
gotta do it yeah he thinks he's a lot
more funny than he really is
we'd be doing this all day
slippery oh you got he got that pressure
for you guys today we'll be close by YV
man one of my favorite guys he's my
coach my the hut hut shot
all right so Hut it's a hut
Wow
that was great Dean better good thing
you guys are playing good football
seriously because your talent off the
field is questionable do you have any
hidden town yeah I'm double-jointed look
at this stuff
boom boom you can't do that I can
moonwalk - and I was born on the same
day as Michael Jackson but there is no
effing way I'm moon dancing moonwalking
on this yes yes you can walk for real
again yeah a real for right for real for
real I can do the alphabet backwards and
I know a lot of Heisman Trophy winners
oh my talents aren't hidden right here
in front of you right in your face uh we
have a guy that's very talented on and
off the field Reggie Bush it's time for
an untold story and this is great it's
the first time in his life that he got
drunk and it's because of a lady and not
just any woman no not just anyone
everyone thinks you're like Johnny
superstar with hair like you must have
been sex drugs and rock and roll in
college right but like we know that
you're this woman's person to drink 22
years old drink but you did have a drink
at 22
yeah why all of a sudden whoa it was to
impress a chick
we were in Vegas we went to town this
was back when tower was like you know it
was that big high so that is peak a huge
Buddha Buddha right champagne bottles
you know coming non-stop and the first
drink I decide is gonna be my first
drink ever is patron straight from the
bottle
no chasers just great tequila but I
can't get over is your Reggie Bush in
there the man and you needed the liquid
courage for whatever reason
I needed a liquid courage to get me
there you get me to that point and I
blacked out right I wake up the next
morning there's my throat is burning I
don't know why my throat's burning then
I look on the side of the bed there's
throw-up all on the side and I'm like
damn like what happened I got the
hangover from hangover hangover from
hell
so I'm my drink of water and all kinds
of stuff the next day all my boys like
man you won't fire less I was like
really dude one of my other boys is like
you turn into the Incredible Hulk like
you just get really strong for no reason
they were like you were picking people
up you were moving people out the way oh
my god I've seen those guys yeah
you were Frank the tank that was Frank
to say so Big B star Heisman Trophy rich
Reggie but did it work at least it did
okay it works but yeah this was a big
price that's a big price to pay
hopefully Reggie's not on the hot seat
yeah thank you Mike his life on blast he
told the story knew what he was signing
up for a comfortable setting it is that
time of the year though where people are
talking about coaches on the hot seat
all right so here's what I want you to
do I'm gonna give a coach's name you
give me the amount of fire emoji sketch
it which their seat is represented right
right
first ones Mike McCarthy in the pack
whoa hot seat oh it's like I mean on the
emoji scale I'm gonna give it about a
six right now six ten six of ten yes I
mean hey Mike McCarthy I think that we
all know some of the struggles they've
had lack of imagination with their
offense they have Aaron Rodgers who is
certainly one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all times I don't think
anybody would argue that and it's not
been good lately they have not supported
him well it's been a lot of Rodgers
making it happen on its own and I think
people are finally realizing that it's
the first year where I'm seeing people
actively blame him yes right exactly
what's interesting right let's go with
another tenured guy yeah second longest
tenured coach in the NFL Marvin Lewis
oh man that's the seats I thought it's
been hot for years well it's hot
certainly I'm not cheeks are warm I'm
leaving it I'm leaving at 7:00 emojis
they're so more than McCarthy or the
McCarthy yeah I just think that the way
the Bengals have played lately
the defense basically falling apart I
mean it's supposed to be his dick has a
chance to set the record for most yards
allowed in that full season you know
lack of playoff one wins he's had a good
run
I just think hey everything's got to
come to an end at some point and the
organization seems like it's kind of
plateaued the last few years all right
what about Dirk cutter and the Tampa Bay
Bucs yeah that's hot I mean that's
burning hot so hot I think he's going to
get fired okay I wanted to keep it you
did a good job
I think that's like a nine emoji nine
fire Wow deep work yeah you're pretty
sure it's over I think so I mean they've
really made no progress the last few
years there's been the quarterback
issues you had a fire Mike Smith you
know they finally got some offensive
talent down there last year with that on
Jackson and people and nothing's really
happened they're not winning football
you don't have an identity though
exactly right I think he's done let's
stay local New York Jets Todd Bowles
whoo hot ten emojis hundred emojis my
yeah it's over now ones like that the
chairs already in Flint I mean put the
whole screen in emojis okay it's done
yes I mean from what Todd Bowles
you know again you have made the pie
offs the first year but ever since then
it's been underwhelming okay then this
year you dropped a rookie quarterback
you get off to a decent start and then
the team falls apart losses like to the
Buffalo Bills at home where you get
blown out that's not gonna save your job
they just haven't made a lot of progress
and I do I think you're gonna see a
regime change he got the dreaded we'll
examine this after the season yes right
when you hear that impending doom yes
but we don't want any of these guys to
get fired no we like them it's just part
of the business and if you want to hire
me as head coach left coach is a pretty
darn good head oh yeah that well that'll
be good I'm Brian Westbrook and you're
watching Sims and Lepke
so for Thanksgiving we had to bring Ali
the Oracle back gave him three games and
I'm just gonna tell you the dude nailed
it let's go back to Ali's newsstand not
one not two but three games on
Thanksgiving you did the damn thing I'm
watching and I'm going he's gonna hit
all your now five and one but more
importantly on Thanksgiving you made
three hundred and forty six dollars and
32 cents is this turning to do a nice
little side gig Adam I'm not even a lot
of you I didn't know we were betting
what do you mean I we didn't talk money
I thought you guys are just friends
cash home various you really didn't know
that was happening absolutely not good
we didn't talk no cash we were friends
talking about football that's it this
game I think could be the game of the
week
Dallas is hosting the saints and the
saints are seven and a half point
favorites in Dallas
you just won on the Saints last Thursday
what are you thinking for this Thursday
I want on a Dallas pseudo that's true
they both hooked you up but seven and a
half in Dallas you got to go with you
Reese
you gotta go right now yes jewelry's is
clicking I don't think that Dallas his
defense is gonna get to them enough to
shake them up that is the key yep and
make sure you tell your buddy Chris yeah
that went against me with every game
last week Chris won oh and three on
Simpson left oh yeah I'm the horrible
[Laughter]
so my big beautiful best friend other
than you
Ali is back three and Oh last week he's
going Saints minus seven and a half
times yeah how dare he takes a shot at
me a big shot II I mean well I'm using
air down the camera geez I know where
your stand is I will come find you and I
like that didn't he already lose why is
he on this show still he's 5 and 1 on
the season you and Owen three more
recycling guests already but okay
who are you going Saint circle I'm going
with him this week yeah I like the
Saints in this matchup I don't think
it's a good matchup for the Dallas
Cowboys
okay Dallas Cowboys that great run
offense well it's the number one run
defense in football if there's a
weakness of the Saints that is their
secondary I don't know if Dallas is past
games good enough to take advantage of
it and as awesome as Dallas as defense
is and their defensive front I think you
and I both agreed the best offensive
line in football is the New Orleans
Saints and Drew Brees gets the ball out
and like to say exactly right with Sean
Payton game planning all of that
together really find some lanes and
pounds that right and we see how the
Saints handle that kind of that kind of
game well the other thing I'm gonna say
is no team in the NFL had a better week
last week than the New England Patriots
Chiefs lost to the RAM right Melvin
Gordon's hurt and they play the Chargers
next week out Pittsburgh loses a game to
Denver up and don't look now New England
is firmly in the two-seed one game
behind the cheese yeah and we might be
looking at the Patriots getting
home-field advantage out of nowhere I
mean this is why I told you to get the
tattoos I said this is what it was I
mean would you you doubted me you
doubted me I'm just gonna listen Ally
from now on what okay I picked those
winners they just didn't pick the spread
the screw betting I'm gonna find Ally
I'm gonna kick his butt forces peace out
Ally and armies on the lef koe man sorry
yes we'll holla holla holla JM I'm
flustered join the games
Ally's in his head
[Music]
you get a tighter shirt actually I do
like these got the top but I think
you're getting more muscular hey what's
up homies thanks for watching subscribe
to the BR YouTube channel
man you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot other videos
check them out and then what time does
our show come out Wednesday 8 p.m. be
there or be square
he ruined it it was really close